hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well one of the absolutely key and
Central ideas that Kant is introducing
in his proma to any future me
metaphysics and elaborating in part two
of the transcendental question is that
of pure concepts of the understanding
and the German for this
is so concepts of the faculty of the
understanding and it turns out the
understanding is doing an awful lot and
is you might say filled up with a lot of
these Concepts and if we look at section
onward we're going to get a lot of
really cool diagrams in just a minute he
says to prove that the possibility of
experience so far as it rests upon pure
a priori that's part of what it means
here concepts of the understanding we
must
first
represent what belongs to judgments in
general now why do we need to do this so
he's going to tell us that these are
concepts of intuition on Sha which could
be sensibility uh perception right but
in general Uber help a very important
term that he uses at several points we
have um you know intuitions in general
intuitions as uh the class of things we
also have Consciousness as individual
Consciousness and as as Consciousness in
general as he's going to bring up as
well and what we want to do is look at
how these actually work so what he's
going to tell us
here is that we um must first represent
what belongs to judgments in general and
the various moments or functions of the
understanding of them and we're going to
be looking at that in a table in just a
moment and then he says and here the the
German and the English translation don't
run themselves an exact parallel because
this notion of running parallel uh is is
uh you know sort of made front and
center right uh so he says these pure
concepts of the understanding must run
parallel to the moments moments of what
of the understanding in judgments and so
what are these uh that the pure concepts
of understanding are running parallel to
while we got to back up a little bit or
actually Jump Ahead in the English text
a little bit says these concepts are
nothing more than concepts of intuition
in general so
far as these are determined btim right
by one or other of these moments of
judging in themselves
necessarily and universally so the act
of judging something that our
understanding is doing all the time
whether we're paying attention to it or
not is something that these pure
concepts of understanding are reflecting
so this is where we get to these
interesting tables which you can of
course look up in the text
yourself and these correspond quite
famously to you know what Kant is going
to be talking about later on as as
categories as well so he tells us he
goes on a little bit more and he says
that um hereby also the AR priori
principles of the possibility of all
experience as objectively valid
empirical cognition will be precisely
determined why they're nothing but
propositions which subsume all
perception conformably to certain
Universal conditions of intuition under
those pure concepts of the understanding
so uh we're not yet getting what the
pure concepts of the understanding are
but they are running
parallel to these these tables one of
the tables however is going to be of the
concepts of the understanding so let's
look at the first one right K Begins by
setting out a logical table of judgments
and you'll find this in the proma you'll
also find this in the critique of pure
reason and there's a much Fuller
treatment there that we're not going to
worry about or go into so he talks about
four kinds
or four whatever you want to call them
classes of judgments there's judgments
about quantity there's judgments about
quality there's judgments about relation
and there's judgments about modality so
this these are
logical uh not in the sense of doing
like formal logic that you might do in a
logic class but rather how do we
actually
classify judgments or what corresponds
to them propositions or cogn itions how
do we classify them in their greatest
generality so in respect of quantity we
have Universal like all s is p we have
particular we have singular with each of
these there's going to be three right so
we have 12 total with respect to Quality
we have affirmative negative and what
Kant calls infinite right uh in relation
to relation we have categorical
hypothetical
and disjunctive disjunctive is saying
either this or that right and then as to
modality problematic assertoric
apodictic right and apodictic is a term
that Kant uses a lot astoic just means
saying well this is the case right
problematic this could be the case um
and as to the apodictic this must be the
case right so what do we have here we
have ways of combining
in um intuitions or other kinds of
judgments within a framework a framework
that could be you know yielding us
judgments or propositions that are you
know Universal and negative right
um so this is what allows us to make
sense out of what it is that we are
encountering and then he goes on to the
trans transcendental table of concepts
of the understanding and here we're
working with the same four big things
quantity quality relation
modality but now we have for quantity
Unity
plurality and totality right so three
different ways again of thinking about
quantity of matters I won't say things
but just the thing the the matters that
we are at actually grasping in
perception in experience talking about
referencing thinking about judging about
quality reality negation and
limitation in relation here's where we
get to very interesting metaphysical
stuff right substance
cause community and then modality
possibility existence necessity and you
might say okay that's all great but what
good does this do us well for Kant it's
not that we're going to be doing
something with these right away in any
sort of special and productive you know
exercise Kant is saying we are using
these all of the time we've been using
them so long as human beings have been
thinking judging speaking you know
engaging in judgment cognition and
proposition right so it's important to
lay these out even though it might seem
a little bit common sensical to some of
you and it might also seem kind of
arbitrary to others we get to see the
upshot of this when we move on a little
bit further skipping over the pure
physiological table of the universal
principles of natural science which
we'll come to later on so he says here's
a very important Proviso in order to
comprise the whole matter in one idea
first we have to remind the reader we're
discussing not the origin of experience
but what lies in experience we're not
doing as he calls it empirical
psychology we are trying to think of how
experience actually works for us so he
says experience consists of
intuitions we already know this right
and those are given to us from
sensibility and he said says judgments
which are entirely a work of the
understanding okay so so far so good um
this seems like something that we
already knew from earlier on in the the
proma but then he says uh this the
judgments which the understanding makes
entirely out of sensuous intuitions are
far from being judgments of experience
so what makes it it a judgment of
experience he says uh
the judgments must Express what
experience in general and not what the
mere perception contains so the Judgment
of experience must add to the
sensuous intuition right which we've
already got and to the uh Judgment of
the understanding uh it's logical
Connection in a judgment something that
determines the synthetic judgment is
necessary and therefore is universally
valid what could this be so Kant is
going to tell us the only thing this
could actually be is the concept the B
which represents the
intuition as determined in itself with
regard to one form of judgment rather
than another that's not in the intuition
itself right and it is you could say in
the judge J M that is connecting it with
other things through the understanding
but what we're doing here is we're
saying well what kind of judgment are we
actually making this is where we can you
know say uh it's a judgment about
plurality it's a judgment about cause or
uh if we go back to the logical table of
judgments it's an apodictic
Universal uh affirmative judgment right
we can
clarify these types of judgments and
these are Universal these are General
these are Uber right so he goes on and
he
says that this is a concept of a
synthetic we're putting things together
Unity of intuitions which can only be
represented by a given logical function
of judgments so we're inevitably using
the pure concepts of the understanding
which are either already contained in
the one of these tables or correspond to
run parallel to uh these these moments
of judgment and so he says um if we
think about how we unite representations
intuitions in a Consciousness which is
Judgment which is the same thing as
thinking right he says that they can be
merely subjective when they're referred
to a Consciousness in one subject only
and you're United in it so you know we
have this sort of thing happening all
the time nothing wrong with those that's
how we get by as individuals in the
world but we can go beyond that he says
they are objective when they are united
in a Consciousness in
general you know Uber the Consciousness
that all of us have and we could say
could participate in that is necessarily
and so he says The Logical moments of
these judgments are so many ways of
uniting representations in Consciousness
and if they serve as
Concepts they are concepts of the
necessary unification of representations
in a Consciousness and so are
principles of
universally valid judgments or
objectively valid judgments and he says
you can either do this by making
analytic judgments by Identity or
synthetic by combining and adding
various representations to one another
and this is what he says experience
actually consists in synthetic
connection of appearances in
Consciousness so far as this connection
is necessary so you know we can talk
about like well my experience if it's
just your experience only subjectively
valid it's not what cont is calling
experience here right for it to be
possible experience in the conscience
sense it has to be everybody's possible
experience and he says that the pure
concepts of the understanding are those
Concepts under which all perceptions
must first be subsumed before they can
serve for judgments of experience so
these you could say precede in a certain
way the uh judgments that we actually
make because
K thanks all of us as human beings as
Consciousness have to judge in the same
way now we can make mistakes of course
we can misidentify things but we the the
possibility of doing that is predicated
on recognizing that there are
objectively
valid holding for everybody ways of
properly judging and those are using
these pure concepts of the understanding
so we get to find out what these are by
looking closely at the very activity of
engaging in judgments of experience and
now we've got these Concepts to work
with
that